all right let's get into hatred mail if
you've never heard about hatred mail
before here's what it is because it's
time to make America hate again hatred
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom
alright this week's hatred mail doesn't
really require an introduction do any of
them ever really require an introduction
but this week's really doesn't other
than I guess to say this relates to
something about Ivanka Trump having her
clothing line made in a Chinese
sweatshop that that's sort of the
universe were operating in let's take a
listen to it David Pakman show you're a
disgrace
you are either extremely mentally
deficient or you're morally corrupt
Trump is a billionaire so he could
therefore make the decision to
manufacture in the US and pay the
increased cost then raise the prices on
his products to compensate for the
decrease in margin of higher prices
would drive sales away to his lower
priced competitors money would dry up
accounts for would go negative and
before long he'd no longer own the
company nor be a billionaire then who
are you going to tax a comrade I'll
leave you with a quote from a female no
less since I assume you fancy yourself a
feminist judging by the sweater over
collared shirt combo you've got down it
Cox are us regular old Warren Buffett
there huh really knows how to run a
business that that hatred i times we're
sweaters yeah does that are sweaters now
only feminists wear sweaters that's a
sort of weird thing i didn't think so
but overall i thought that hey treat
male was relatively coherent I know
that's rare Cox R Us is actually kind of
funny yeah it's almost slightly clever
which is not usually the case when it
comes to these hey travails I proposed
this guy become the leader of the
hatreds because he seems the most able I
wouldn't give anybody any ideas we get
it we get enough emails as it is but
that that's let's let's jot that one
down and under the maybe category pad
you can turn hatred mail into something
positive we have a coupon code Patriot
forty it will
gave you 40 percent off of membership at
david pakman.com slash membership